one of my favorite jokes of yours is the
the mexicans stealing our jobs oh yeah
yeah
the joke is absolutely brilliant and
so well put together thank you i should
put that [ __ ] up before there's no more
mexicans here
dude
and talking about that joke for just a
second sure did it start with you
hearing maybe in conversation people
saying mexicans are stealing our jobs
and then you just take it to this whole
other level how did you kind of develop
that joke
the the mexicans are stealing the jobs
you ever people say that
you never heard that you never heard
that
lion ass [ __ ] around
i've always had like a an affinity um
for mexicans and mexican culture you
know i lived in spain and i came back to
california
and i worked in restaurants with these
guys who
literally would work uh
18 hours a day um seven days a week six
seven days a week
i have families here send money back to
their families there and they tell me
these amazing stories of how they got
into america and like
just hearing about what they're
able to do just to support their
families back home
i i just had this real i don't know i
was just i just thought they were just
such a special people man
like really special people yeah and i
would hear people say nah they're still
in the jobs that kind of stuff like that
it just didn't sit right to me so it
was my way of kind of like defending
defending these people who i didn't
think were stealing jobs i thought they
were
doing the american thing that we've done
for years here which is a new immigrant
class comes and
they do the jobs nobody else wants to do
and that's how it started
first of all that's the stupidest thing
i ever heard in my life how the [ __ ] do
you steal
a job
i never seen a mexican walk into a
restaurant give me the dishes
that [ __ ] never happened in my [ __ ]
no no we don't want the money rubber
gloves
[Laughter]
but then to actually make it funny like
we're like oh give me your dishes
and all that yeah yeah i just thought it
was kind of
like that's how things happen to me like
the idea of like like i'll think about
something
i'll be honest the one thing that annoys
me about that joke is it's likable
like the joe the joke is pretty likeable
like i think most people have
you know a a little bit of compassion
for mexican immigrants
right i don't i tend to gravitate
towards humor that
you have no compassion for definitely
and then you defend it and then i defend
it right
so so this is this is a joke that like
i'm kind of like a good guy on
which is the one thing i don't like
about that being said it's like
something i do believe
you know what i mean i like being a bad
guy in every joke so stupid
if you're gonna steal a job
wouldn't you steal a great job
like who is deciding to steal these
[ __ ] jobs that's what i wanna
are you ready to steal some jobs today
yeah minimum wage we can do work
but that's what it comes to is like you
hear somebody say something they're
stealing the jobs or even like with the
grab the [ __ ] thing
and like i'll just ruminate on that i'm
like grabbing the [ __ ] is it wrong to
grab the [ __ ] like how do you grab a
[ __ ] like how do you
well how do you have i ever grabbed a
[ __ ] yeah i've grabbed it matter of
fact i've
i've always grabbed poison i never asked
for permission to grab [ __ ] i just
grabbed [ __ ] right
so like that's where it goes right yeah
you know instead of just like
accepting conventional wisdom which is
all these people think it's wrong okay i
think it's wrong
yeah it's impressive that you you did
that joke and you're like but you've
never met a billionaire you had women
clapping yeah yeah that's that i mean
that's just amazing to just flip
people like that it's it was really fun
to watch i'm glad you liked it
yeah man it was it was great to see you
work live and it was great for you to
share this time with me man my brother
i really appreciate your generosity for
sure i wish they would steal a good
i wish 40 mexicans would just raid the
apple store
the genius bar is ours
the [ __ ] out of here nerds it's
mexicans to run the apple store or not
just got nerds walking what are you
making something about silly max
if we can sell oranges we can sell
apples okay get the [ __ ] out of it
this [ __ ] is easy hey hot brother and
sister
if you love comedy as much as we do here
at hot breath
click the subscribe button to join the
hop retheverse and then watch more
videos to get even more comedy tips